[Music]
these are the three top-selling oat milk
brands in the u.s
but this is probably the one you're most
familiar with that's because a few years
ago oatley overhauled its marketing
strategy taking its products from sweden
to grocery stores around the world
including the us
before oatley expanded in the u.s oat
milk was relatively unknown to the u.s
consumer it was really oatley that
started the oatmeal category in the u.s
but the company has a problem just look
at their stock price
it dropped in part because oatley can't
keep up with the demand for oat milk
demand that it largely created here's
why oatley a one-time wall street
darling that brought oat milk to the
american stage has lost market share to
rivals
let's rewind to 2019 when demand for
oatley was rising thanks to quirky
advertisements and placement in
independent coffee shops
ceo tony peterson had brought his
longtime friend john schoolcraft to
oatley to build a creative department
and we came up with this line it's like
milk but made for humans
very simple he created a team which
jokingly calls itself the oatley
department of mind control and rebranded
with slogans like wow
no cow
but that wasn't the only tactic oatley
used oatley developed relationships with
baristas in independent third wave
coffee shops and it really became
interesting cool and alternative amongst
this niche market and then the barista
started talking about it on social media
and as one of the only oat milk
producers on the market they helped
create a craze since 2019 the oat milk
market in the u.s has grown by roughly
330 percent to maintain their buzzy
status oatley needed to be able to
produce enough oat milk to actually meet
that demand and that was becoming a
problem at first oatley had relied on
contractors which was expensive compared
to making it themselves so oatley built
its first u.s factory in millville new
jersey but it didn't go as planned
production at the millville plant
started about six months behind target
and it was hampered by poor planning
there was wastewater issues as well as
equipment malfunctioning an oatley
spokeswoman said there was no wastewater
treatment system initially planned for
millville and that one was added in
august 2021. all wastewater from the new
facility has been within permit range
she said
she added that it is best practice to
scale production quickly to resolve
technical issues and the approach didn't
cause delays affect output or increase
cost she said that by any metric our
millville facility is best in class in
construction execution safety and
quality
in late 2018 oatley had purchased a
second factory in ogden utah but it
didn't solve their problems and in fact
it created more
at the ogden utah plant there was two
major problems one they spent more than
they intended they had hoped to spend 50
million and they spent over 100 million
and then second they didn't finish on
time they had hoped to finish by early
2020 and took way longer than that an
oatly spokeswoman said the executives
frequently updated the board on changes
to the budget adding that the budget was
in line with other modern facilities she
also said that many of the challenges at
the ogden facility have been compounded
by the pandemic but the company has made
continuous improvements
in 2021 oatley's market share in the u.s
was 26 of retail sales that's a decrease
of 6 percent from 2019 and stock prices
have followed soon meanwhile competitors
saw demand for oatmeal grow and
shortages of oatly allowed them to swoop
in and snag market share dairy giant hp
hood launched planet oat which hood says
sells for one to two dollars less than
competing brands
planet oat overtook oatley in 2021 and
now leads the u.s retail market another
dairy company chobani made their first
venture into plant-based products with
oat milk in late 2019. chobani said they
constructed a plant within a plant and
that the construction took them less
than 12 months and allowed for far more
capacity than there was demand at the
time
now chobani holds third place in u.s
retail sales after planet oat and oatly
competitors such as hood and chobani
really raced to jump in this market when
oatley was having troubles and they
capitalized on oatley's struggles plus
oatley stock has fallen about 80
since its ipo in may 2021.
that summer the board was considering a
successor to peterson they specifically
wanted a candidate with more operational
experience so peterson could devote his
time to business development people
familiar with the matter said
in april oatley hired a former senior
executive at candy giant mars inc as
president oatley's chairman said in a
statement that the hire was part of the
board's succession planning and that the
company is not considering a transition
right now
operational experience is very important
because oatley is trying to expand its
manufacturing capacity and it's having
production issues and a lot of that
stems from operational issues whoever
leads oatley going forward will face
challenges in may global production
output decreased in the fourth quarter
of 2021 with the company citing pandemic
related factors
oatley's stock hit a low of under three
dollars in may reflecting difficulties
it has had with production the primary
challenge that the new ceo will face has
to do with manufacturing and ensuring
that supply meets demand in the meantime
the oat milk market will continue to be
contested
[Music]
you